hello and welcome to GameSpot's
comprehensive spoiler chat of Red Dead
Redemption - we're gonna try to hit just
about everything we made a nice little
outline here of everything we'd like to
talk about and we've kind of divided up
into chapters my name is Jake I might
over here
howdy Callie alright let's start from
the beginning so the first thing chapter
1 as I put it the gang members and their
fates I figured we just kind of run
through the gang members talked about
how we felt not all of them just some of
the more important ones yeah take a very
long time but anyway the first one I
have here is John we get a wagon full of
some flammable oil put it on the tracks
they see they know they either have to
stop or die you know train driver wants
to be cooked alive is kind of brilliant
we're going to talk about the epilogue
at length so maybe let's stop there I
would say and we are going to talk about
John's relationship with Arthur a bit
later - John generally is a character
yeah John Jenna is a character I know
like talking to you before you had some
concerns and how if you hadn't played
the first one it might be hard to
connect with John yeah I think like at
the beginning of the game especially I
think John is kind of relegated to oh we
all know you like John so we're not
gonna spend a lot of time on John and I
think especially at the first half of
the game there's a lot of time spent on
other characters which I appreciate
as someone who played the first game but
I feel like if you didn't play it you'd
be like who is this [ __ ] and then I
can he swerves and then I I think you
would as the game progresses you'd be
like I why am I supposed to kick like
there's not enough acceptance sometimes
to care about him I think yeah it almost
starts out arthur kind of vocally shows
his distaste for john right at the
beginning so you kind of not really
separate yourself from john but you
don't really interact with him as much
as you do as someone like Charles or
Dutch obviously like he's certainly
positioned at the beginning the aim to
be an [ __ ] too
not only everyone else were kind of
having his little leave of absence after
Jack was born but you know he has the
contention like the rocky relationship
with Abigail yeah
whereas Abigail's character is one who's
super nice to you and so you latch on to
her more than I would say you would
latch on to John but then I think they
managed to do that arc of you know you
guys being so separate and distant from
John and then bringing him into the fold
to the point where you know towards the
end of the game you you refer to him as
your brother it also establishes it like
the number one sin in this gang is
disloyalty or like leaving obviously
later on that becomes huge with Arthur
because it's a struggle for him to stop
being loyal to Dutch and kind of have
his own splinter group within the gang
but John leaving is like the cardinal
sin for them and then also like so when
you're going to save him there at the
beginning he's like he's not coming back
like we know what he's doing and in
reality he was actually like in danger
from like getting [ __ ] out by wolves
or whatever yeah yeah I think you even
put how its kind of interesting that
John was kind of the disloyal one at
first and Arthur criticized him for it
but near the end
Arthur kind of became more disliked yeah
almost like kind of sees John's not not
so much for abandoning Jack and Abigail
but kind of sees his reasons for wanting
to leave the gang or step away yeah I
think John ends up being a tremendous
influence on Arthur maybe not as much as
other characters which we will get to
but and then Arthur obviously is a huge
influence on John as well so they kind
of had this give-and-take that I really
appreciate but I do think the there
could have been a little bit more done
and maybe that that was a result of me
having to play through the game really
quickly because I was reviewing it and I
had to finish it in a certain amount of
time and so I didn't spend as much time
as I wanted like hanging out the camp
and Rob's famous what Karen video like I
don't get that in here I mean I get to
see stuff like that I tried and i
eavesdropped on other conversations one
of my favorite ones was at Shady Bell he
was asking Abigail it's like move into
his lodging Oh and it was really really
cute and I was like oh he's coming
around he's such an idiot but he's like
really trying with her and so I think
those things are present it's just I
a little bit in the main story for me
yeah that was kind of a little bit
off-topic but that was kind of an issue
with going through the game fast was
that characters like Charles I didn't
get to spend a lot of time with even
though he's one of my favorite I've
heard some of the best missions of the
hunting ones with Charles and Indy like
I only did a couple things with Javier
and I really liked Javier even though he
didn't get a lot of time like in the
main story beside interactions I had
with him were always pretty good Javier
was an improvement from the first game
from what I remember so I haven't played
at first so I like will get into this
but I haven't played the first game in
five years so I don't I just show up
with sombrero half of the story at that
point yeah because I went on a home
robbery with him and I didn't feel like
there was much death to him and to but
he was enjoyable to be around and then
like by the time toward when the yen
rolled around and like he was still
really loyal to Dutch like you know
Bill's going to be well you know they're
both going to be from the first game
bill just kind of seems bills like a
loyal dog it makes sense yeah he needs a
leader
idiot Javier I didn't really understand
enough to be like oh I get why he's with
Dutch but like there's a part where
you're all it's one of the other last
times you're all riding I think it's the
the train robbery in San Denis that goes
wrong
Javier's like what happened to loyalty
I'm like I mean where's this coming from
like I get it like that's kind of again
that makes sense cuz that's how the rest
of the gang is conditioned and like you
want to talk about like biblical
references all the time Dutch's like
you're all apostles of Dutch for most of
the game and then apparently Javier is
still really loyal which again it makes
sense having played the first game and
seeing how his art closes but I didn't
really felt feel like it got there in
the second game yeah I feel like well
like understanding coffee because Javier
is very different from Bill even though
they're both like in the first game as
your antagonists in a way um he seems at
least to me it seemed like more like he
was just out for himself but I thought
at least in two he's given important
nuanced approach to his culture rather
than a giant sombrero so like I like
that he's playing the guitar and singing
songs for people and everyone's like
singing along to take Laura
ice or whatever or uh yeah that scene
after you rescued Jack and he's playing
by the fire that's really good but yeah
I definitely get what you're saying like
that was one of my issues with it like
when we had finished and we talked about
it it just seems strange that Javier was
all of a sudden like super loyal to
Dutch and criticizing you for your your
rebellion yeah part of it is maybe
because Javier wasn't really as involved
with at least the missions that Arthur
was in and John Wetton where you kind of
see yeah Dutchess sort of madness yeah
and he's just kind of there's a
essentially like a bystander yeah he's
just kind of like hey why is everyone
going against the grain I don't
understand what's happened I'm just
gonna you know remain loyal to what I
know yeah so I'm gonna correct myself
wasn't a glorious it was cantando urs so
I really really liked so full disclosure
I love Sadie Adler I think she's my the
most enjoyable rock star character ever
but Dutch I think is the best character
in this game not a good person but he's
a good character I think the more he
it's really cool he brought that up
because the more he unravels and feels
like he's losing control of these people
who is essentially brainwashed the more
he tries to prove himself to the ones
that are doubting him so he knows he
doesn't need to prove anything to bill
or Javier or Micah which is a whole
other thing yeah and then obviously at
the end of shoots him in the stomach but
for like for John and Arthur he knows
those two John especially has been
doubting him for a while and Arthur's
like his if he loses control of Arthur
you lose control the gang is but like in
his mind I'm sure because it's his first
mate pretty much yeah and like the more
he tries to prove to them the more you
see Dutchess really just doesn't know
what he's doing much of the time mm-hmm
yeah you throughout the game you see him
falling apart like you seem kind of
going crazy like not not overtly crazy
but some of the ways he's responding
like there's that one scene I don't know
if you guys Scott but Dutch like
casually just looks at Arthur and he's
like you look like the type who's gonna
betray me it's kind of early I think
it's like halfway through yeah it's like
pretty thinking about like everything
that happens like I'd be weird if I saw
that yeah I the site
about like Dutch and his mismanagement
of the gang is I feel like that results
and this is partly mica - and maybe we
can get to a little bit later but I
think it got really exhausting when
you're like when you figure well if you
go into this game you know he's gonna
lose it and you go into these missions
like why I didn't want to follow him
because I was this is gonna go wrong
like I know this is a bad idea and I
have to do it anyway and I found like I
was fighting against the game a little
bit and I do think that served a
narrative purpose and that like you get
to experience Arthur's inner turmoil in
that way I still touch
yeah there were definitely times when I
feel like the game needed to remind you
that you don't really have choice over
like you don't have too much agency over
what you're doing in the big picture
mm-hmm you're very much playing Arthur's
role despite the fact that you can kind
of change how he interacts with people
in the world it's gonna be Arthur's role
he's still like even at this point the
game when you know Dutch is making
terrible decisions and you don't want to
follow him to Santa knee for this train
robbery Arthur still would because he's
been what 20 years I think they said at
that point so despite the fact that I
felt like there are some points where
the role playing conflicted with the
main story I think overall I was handled
well in my opinion yeah I think it's
just contradictory when you go into this
world where you have a lot of freedom
immediately like almost immediately yeah
kind of go wherever and do whatever I
think that is a little bit contradictory
when you realize I actually don't have
much choice but I do think that was a
good thing by the end which is where I
think the character of Hosea came in
really to kind of say oh yeah you're
wrong with the gang because obviously
you're supposed to love Hosea he's hard
to dislike I think he's one of the like
when you I read Arthur's journal right
away and Hosea was like mentioned
immediately and it was kind of like okay
this is an important character to Arthur
and you really see how I mean he
operates as a opposite to Dutch in a lot
of ways and shows like okay let's temper
this a little bit and you see that
Arthur kind of being split between Jose
and dudgeon I think he was a really good
character in that way yeah I think
Arthur like outright admired Hosea
whereas Dutch he's like I've been of
them so long and he's just the default
leaders the dude yeah he's brilliant but
like yeah Hosea just consistently proved
that he was actually thinking it was I
think it was finally the time the first
time that Dutch makes you and Hosea
kind of he asks for both your opinions
is when you're about I think it's when
you're about to finally pit the
braithwaite's and the greys against each
other you're sitting in the the you're
at Shady bail at this point so maybe
that's incorrect so that would've been
after I don't know he finally asked you
like what your opinion is about like
robbing the bank in San Denis and Hosea
disagrees with you and that's the first
time where I'm like I've I would have
sided with Hosea but again this is
Arthur
story so I guess that makes sense yeah
yeah and Hosea's death too is pretty
important even though it sucked like
that is really what kind of not set
Dutch off necessarily but like you were
saying you kind of like tempers Dutch
and without Hosea you kind of start to
see all these plans get wilder and
wilder and you're just you're like you
like you said you're just there like I
don't want to do this but Arthur Morgan
has to because what else would he do at
this point yeah but it also just made me
hate Milton all that much more when he
shot him yeah we talked a little bit
about Sadie but I think we probably
should talk more about Sadie because it
seems like that is everybody's favorite
you know what they did to me you're the
only one of these foods that I trust
I've got to do this voice actress could
be the lead singer of like an 80s punk
band oh yeah
right or like a jazz band almost like
that raspy oh it's so freaking like a
wild cat yeah when she just goes off and
does a thing Sadie's off as well you see
it from the very beginning but you see
you the beginning of her like the
inciting incident you see like the fire
in her yeah yeah comments on it like
right away he's like keep an eye on her
there's a fire in her eye or something
okay well I just I I like that when you
guys are away when like Arthur and Dutch
and everybody's away in in Guam ah Sadie
like really steps up and you come back
and you see like oh she's actually in a
lot of ways the leader that they needed
at this time I really that just cemented
her for me as I like I just want I want
Sadie DLC like I want to play as her I
wanted like I'd want to do Sadie bounty
hunter DLC because I love her so much I
haven't thought she was gonna be before
I knew that you play as John Marston for
another eight hours for the epilogues I
thought maybe Sadie would be because
because of what you just said she took
over as the like the leader when you
heard away I thought maybe again also
because like aside from Dutch she has
most reason to have beef with the O
Driscoll's yeah if not more than Dutch
cuz I they killed her husband burned her
house down and like I think did some
fucked-up [ __ ] to her
typically but then of course I like I
was like maybe they're gonna do an
epilogue with her because okay again I
haven't played the first game in a while
but do we know how her art how she dies
what happens cuz she gets injured at the
end with Dutch and Micha she's not in
the first game so many of these
characters aren't mentioned in the first
game at all so that's what led me to
maybe think oh maybe she's gonna be the
epilogue cuz I knew there were epilogues
but I didn't know who you play as John
makes sense now in retrospect but I was
like maybe it's Sadie cuz she like
becomes in the epilogue she's just this
bounty hunter but yeah actually have
this trenchcoat a sawed-off shotgun
there's a great scene too at the end
where she asked Arthur to kill the last
of the O'Driscoll is hiding out and that
and he's like I just can't do it and
she's like you're the only one I can
trust
yeah and like rolling up on the
O'Driscoll's and just having that one
final fight it's pretty cool yeah when
the O'Driscoll attack shady Belle and
Arthur everybody's like we're Sadie and
like you see the blip come up on the
radar they're like go save her that was
the the breath that says go help Sadie
and then you get back there she's just
[ __ ] stabbing three Oh Driscoll's at
a time and then yeah that's the first of
three times you see her doused in blood
yeah the second time is with when she
kills that Oh Driscoll and she's just
covered and like she just like likes
killing and that's I love that like she
turned into this bloodthirsty killer
that would traditionally be this like
like several the gang members like the
men in the gang or like that but she's
just like enjoys she even tells um the
the guy from del lobos that you're
capturing in the epilogue she tells him
she's like I just like fighting and even
more I like killing and you're like I I
know I've seen that it's like scary I
like that about her because she I mean
the whole game you have Arthur's like
moral conflict and like his internal
turmoil and then if John as a character
has the same thing where he's trying to
be good and sayd he's just like I'm past
that like they ruined my life
this is my life now and I really
appreciate that about her is like seeing
a different side of of what their
lifestyle does to somebody like she's
just kind of like I had a life and now I
don't so I'm gonna just kill people yeah
and then like one last thing about that
when I'm when Arthur is pretty much like
planning to help the Marsten's whatever
you
john marston Abigail and Jack get away
and lead a life they're having a
conversation it's either right before
she killed that last Joe Driscoll when
you go to the ranch or after and he says
he's like let's help him get away she's
like whatever like why and then he's
like because we're both ghosts of people
but they still have a chance she's like
yeah I know and like so like her and
Arthur I think have that kinship they
know yeah he's dying from tuberculosis
he also has done [ __ ] that he can't
really make up for like I think they
both know that like they're beyond
saving kind of so like let's help these
people which makes the first game all
that more kind of impactful I think yeah
so I want to move on to the next topic
talking point talking point but first we
haven't touched on Micah really at all
and we haven't touched on Charles I
guess I can start with Charles I think
he is probably my favorite character and
I really like how he shows up in the
epilogue again which we can talk about
more I'm bummed I missed a lot of those
hunting missions because they sounded
really good but he was kind of he kind
of felt like a guiding light to Arthur
at times which I thought was really cool
and his backstory all the backstory we
got from him although it wasn't much I
thought was really well done as for
Micah he's super well written
he's like the Grima Wormtongue yeah
everything and it was so infuriating
like playing as Arthur and you can
obviously clearly see exactly and you
can completely identify with Arthur's
frustration yeah he knows what's going
on and he's trying to point it out and
you're kind of like sitting there
screaming at the TV go look what he's
doing and just everyone else acting
oblivious and turning it back on Arthur
I just thought he was annoying as [ __ ]
but he was so well written mm-hmm I've
never I don't think I've ever hated is
particularly a rockstar antagonist as
much as I hated Micah yeah yeah and I
was so surprised to find out that he was
the one snitching like it makes sense
but I did not see that coming I was
totally on board with like I was Molly
she's pissed off done much yeah and all
she was was like into Dutch and I saw
him being like you're so beautiful and I
was like are Molly and Dutch together
there was a one mission at Shady Bell
where she is the quest giver and you go
up and talk to her all of a sudden Dutch
comes up he's like sorry I gotta talk to
Arthur and then yeah all right well but
that makes sense later on but I was like
well she keeps getting slighted by yet
so make when she comes in she's like
yeah I told her I was like Oh duh this
is what you get from egging moly O'Shea
it was such a good baton switches and
then when it was Mike I was like oh that
makes so much more sense but I was kind
of because you see him like he's kind of
like Bill in a way where they both are
kind of like rough billa's is far far
more like he's kind of an idiot hey I
was working for rat yeah but I kind of
saw them as like Elementary yeah and so
in my mind I think that positions Micah
to be loyal when he's in fact not and so
I think that was a really smartly done
arc where he's just you hate him he he's
very easy to hate but you also don't
expect him to betray anyone either
despite his total insanity I thought the
way that it would go down was that he
would do stuff from within like
purposefully mess up rather than
snitching to the agents I thought he was
just gonna you know at one point during
the night go around and kill everyone
and take everything yeah but then you
know he was doing the stitching and kind
of working things out there from the
outside there are a few times during the
game where like again like to go back to
like them comparing them to Dutch to
Jesus and like them you're you being the
apostles he calls you Mike is the first
one to call Arthur doubting Thomas like
several times I was like well Arthur's
Thomas then who's the Judas and then I
was like I I just expected it was Micah
because I've looked around he had the
most motive to do and he was also new
he's that stare like arc arc typical
this new guy that no one trusts but like
the leader vouches for him so he's like
a mr. blonde so I was like I was like
okay maybe it's him but then of course
like you don't find out until you're
going after millon and then before Adam
Arthur also like mentions multiple times
when he stuff even he says it like
directly to Micah like things were going
great until you showed up but now
Blackwater this and this and this and
everything's falling apart
me since you've been riding with us
thing but nothing but trouble start
things up all the time getting the
Dutchess here
she's wherever you is this pink
attention vice versa so you better watch
your goddamn mouth boy
take it easy cowboy
you're gonna do yourself a mischief way
your head Micah shut he started it yeah
I think it's hard to blame him
integrally because you see Dutch
continually make poor decisions in
addition to having the cops called on
them essentially he's still not making
great decisions so it's like yeah kind
of hard to suss out what the actual
source of the problem is I think Micah
recognizes the really dark side of Dutch
and like massaged it to try to bring it
out and like so he's it's not like he's
not the source of it but he's definitely
like like a he stoked the flames for
sure he's doing it on multiple fronts
yeah
[Applause]
and then we have Ghormeh so this was a
big surprise yeah
whether you liked it or not I'd still
say it was a pretty big surprise how you
wash up on shore in an island off of
Cuba and all of a sudden take part in a
in a sugar war essentially yeah so I
felt the shipwreck there seemed to be
something cut from that sequence when
you board the ship and then something
happens and then BAM shipwreck I felt
like there was something some sort of
mission in between I could see that yeah
I thought Guam was fine it certainly
wasn't my favorite section it was kind
of it was very short I don't think it
served that much to the whole Ground
like the rest of the story I felt like I
could have done without it
I like saying I like the area but I mean
the missions that were not very
memorable for me yeah I feel like it
it's similar to Mexico in the first game
and that you're kind of getting into a
thing that doesn't concern you but that
the better version of that comes after
Burma with rains fall and eagle flies so
I felt like and I felt like for me it
didn't advance my understanding of the
gang much at all it was just kind of
like oh we gotta save Javier like and
I'm like well yeah because I know he
lives like that was the point in that
game where I was like okay just get to
the point because I'm first of all it's
like Monday I need to write this review
but also I was I was just kind of like
yeah everything's going wrong and I'm
tired I'm so tired so I agree that it
seemed like some missions were cut and
the missions there weren't that good
like they were fine like it was mostly
just like you're in a small place and
you shoot people until the end of the
mission you trigger a cutscene however I
think that whole thing was super
important for this story and I think we
kind of talked about this a little too
but after first of all I mean just like
the fact that they robbed that huge Bank
the whole place is the whole place is
like on red alert
having them get away I think is
important for the NER
just in that sense like they just need
to be away for a little bit and then I
think another important thing is that
you're with all of the villains of the
game essentially you're with Dutch mica
bill and Xavier and Arthur I feel like
really gets a sense of who those people
are when they are separated from the
rest of the gang I think that's a very
good point and then most importantly I
think you see Duchess like insanity and
I think Arthur would have only seen that
insanity if he was far removed from
reality essentially in this other place
and he kills that lady and he's like why
did you do it it's like she was gonna
betray us and he's like betray us like
do you even know what she's saying he's
like I know some Spanish and then you
climb up the ladder and you come up the
ladder and then he and then he's
Arthur's like are you gonna choke me out
to Dutch and he's like he's like she was
gonna betray us and he's like how did
you know and he's like I could see in
her eyes like I thought you knew Spanish
yeah and he's like let's just get Xavier
yeah and I think that scene is yeah
we're good super-important I don't think
that could have happened anywhere else
yeah I agree with that I just don't
think the warmest sequence was
necessarily well executed right I think
it could have been executed better like
without getting involved in that sugar
warned that I think the thing that I'm
probably focusing on more is just the
relentless hey there's all these people
coming I'm gonna have to shoot them I
felt like it was more bloated than that
concentrated moment like that yes the
trade moment was great but then the
Whydah surrounding missions would just
kind of dragged it down that's fair like
the last mission of a mediocre uncharted
uncharted and I've never played
Uncharted but I was like the I know I
know what it's like okay so like I saw
happen with you I'm with you too I don't
think it was executed well I think I
totally see the necessity of that so
it's also a I love that so throughout
the the game before that the number one
provision that I looked for was warmer
rom because it helps your Deadeye and
your health it was better than Kentucky
Bourbon yes or cigarettes and cigars
didn't drain your health course that's
your health course so like right from
that was drinking that the whole game
and then doing like oh I'm on Gorman
that establish like the that's a [ __ ]
up like like the remnants of the like
molasses sugar slave trade which like is
still very much a thing here even though
they don't always talk about it and I
liked that they kind of you know like
it's Anthony is stand in for New Orleans
and then Guam Oh was a sent like kind of
this stand-in for like yeah actual sugar
plantations they they hint at it
throughout the game to even from the
first trainer our mission when you first
hit Cornwall one of the documents you
pick up Arthur's like sugar trade like
what is this about they hinted it more
throughout the game yeah and I did
notice that till I played it the second
time yeah and then it's like okay they
are kind of getting at this which is
clever but yeah once again I understand
that those missions I don't think were
particularly good the rest and then like
lastly I think going to guara and so
Duchess plan up to that point was let's
escape to Tahiti or Australia will
escape America and then we'll be fine
and like it sounds to us it sounds so
[ __ ] far-fetched like are you gonna
go to Tahiti and or Australia well
Australia's not as far-fetched but like
you actually finally get outside you go
there you see that there are still
problems elsewhere and you see that like
not only is Dutch and the people that
are loyal to him worse they like their
true selves come out but like you see
that that plan holds no water you can
run from it you can't run from your
problems which is very much a theme of
John Marsten's as well like you're not
gonna escape this I think Arthur finally
realizes that like it's over I can't run
from what you've done and yeah and like
so when you go back to it one of the my
favorite moments in this whole game was
when you go when you first get back off
the boat and that song is playing as
you're riding back to check on shady
Bell yeah
[Music]
you stand up shake
that's when you're finally looking at it
you're like I think Arthur's like okay I
need to face the music I'm probably
gonna die here because he doesn't know
he has TB at that point yet I don't
think he does
no no yeah cuz that's when you come back
to but he's been coughing and that's
right where I was like I'm dying yeah
yeah I I will say like with most of my
problems with this game this is also
true for ghormeh is that the things that
maybe weren't good in the moment or I
didn't quite enjoy in the moment I oh I
felt always did serve a purpose save for
a couple small things and that's
ultimately like why I chose 9 instead of
10 because it was like okay I have these
problems I think they do serve a greater
purpose and at the end of the game I
really appreciated them for like Ferg
warme being like a narrative Lee really
key but I just it just like wasn't quite
there for me like I I'm with you on like
I was tired of the shoot a bunch of guys
get a cutscene she had much more guys
get another cutscene structure at that
point but I think it all adds to your
fatigue and then that makes the turning
point that much better so it's just it
was hard for me it's like a lot of
rockstar games where in retrospect I was
like oh that was kind of brilliant in
but not when you're playing is like that
wasn't executed all that well yeah and
so I felt about the majority of gta4
looking back I'm like oh I loved that
but then like going back to play that
game was like [ __ ] no I know it took me
so long yeah I was replaying that
recently as it's a bit tough to play
it's a bit unfair because it's an older
game like e85 but like almost all
rockstar games and I love rockstar games
especially Red Dead Redemption to like
having just finished it yesterday but
like a finishing up a few last things
like an hour ago from now it's now my
game of the year but it wasn't until the
ending because I wasn't like always
enjoy yeah you really need to get to the
ending and like take the time to
appreciate those small things almost to
like palate cleanser things that are
hard to get through in the moment
because you do realize like I mean you
guys pointing out certain things about
dwarma gives me a greater appreciation
for ghormeh than I did when I came in
this room but I when I came in this room
I was like
you know so like you do need to take the
time to think about those things and I
think narrative lis that is really smart
but I also think that video game
narratives don't always need to be the
same as other narratives in other media
so there's ways that I would have
appreciated it done that could have been
better for me yeah moving on to chapter
six kind of right after Guana this is
when things kind of start to when the
[ __ ] hits the fan as they say you find
out our threats tuberculosis John has
been captured the Shady Bell has like
fallen apart and they've moved I don't
know there's a lot to talk about in this
chapter I guess we can kind of start
with the big one which is tuberculosis
which is pretty sad but brilliant also
like we were talking a little bit about
how the game has you manage your health
and so on and there's even a thing that
says like that says like sickness
everyone in like not this part slack was
like so do you thinking it like a cold
or something and I'm just like like a
guide on sickness and we were like yeah
that's that's what's I was texting you
right after I found out so I so like
many people I noticed he was coughing it
is he I thought I honestly didn't know
what I thought like but and then every
time you ate something more than like or
smoked or drank anything haha
this is weird and then finally you go
back to San Denis and you just collapse
but that was done so yeah it didn't feel
like it was like a main mission like on
a street and you're heading to see Sadie
at least for me yeah it was in the
middle of something I collapsed I was
texting Jake like what's going on did I
[ __ ] up I love like the whole point in
that game like even during the preview
season of this game when we're all like
oh yeah they're just going for this
detail porn like you are you are very
much trying to add to the realism or
rockstars trying to add to the realism
by making you manage your weight how
much you eat you're grooming your
shaving you're getting these close-ups
on Arthur's face and you're like oh I
haven't bathed in a while I should bathe
you're getting really attached to his
role and specifically his appearance
so that finally when you start to get
sick I feel like that actually makes you
feel like you're in a sick characters
role because I woke up on and they're
like you're at the minimum weight
requirement like what I just ate like
three grilled venison kind of like what
you were saying how like you're it makes
you think you have all these choices but
you actually don't sound like this it's
like when you get to the end Arthur's
gonna look like [ __ ] no matter why yeah
he really looks like [ __ ] I will say the
weight management didn't impact because
I didn't really notice a physical
difference when I ate enough and I found
what you should see thirty Artie I I
found it and I wrote this in the review
I found it to be more trouble than it
was worth to eat enough to be a normal
weight so I just kind of ignore I was
underweight the entire game so I didn't
have that impact when I was um when he
was sick and it was like you hit bottom
way and I was like I ate biscuits like I
don't know what else to tell you that
can of peaches a week ago yeah but like
I think the the beard and bathing and
going to having to physically go to a
place to bathe and like seeing his body
and seeing like when you're in the
bathtub and you have a lady come in and
it's really awkward and stuff like all
of that contributes to you have one idea
of Arthur and then you see his face
later on well he looks bad
sunken eyes yes like blotchy yeah weird
question is you guys ever I know this is
gonna sound gross did you ever take a
bath as him after he found when he was
really sick no it looks bad like it's
not just his face it's like his body is
also like it's and he's not like
decrepit but he's getting there
so I did that specifically to see like
yeah so I'd love that like they were
building up all these things over the
course of games like I was just adding
to the detail but then like it's like
they wanted you to get attached to these
mechanics so then you could see them
deteriorate no yeah I thought that was
really cool but I wish that I could ever
eat enough to be a normal way oh my god
I'll try cooking meat and see what that
does I couldn't I couldn't do it
I really couldn't manage it yeah we
found out through there through dirty
arty which is just like a show we're
trying to make or sort of look as bad as
possible you have to eat a lot to see a
difference like I am constantly chugging
cans of beans and like yeah but for me
that's like I would rather be doing
literally anything else to do that you
know but also there's a matter of how he
got tuberculosis
it was pretty huge ish I I will say I
was so busy punching that dude I did not
notice he had to pay I did not notice
yeah I knew it had to come back because
I was first of all I was like I don't
really want to do what's-his-name's
missions yes because I feel bad I did so
many of them after that because I was
like well I've got I've come this far
and I did a lot did you finish his quest
line yes the question no no Strauss's
specifically so you you do the final one
when you're at Beaver Hollow
mhm and on both of the last debtors you
have the choice to just pay off there
yourself yeah I did finish that that
wasn't honorable so then he kicked
Straus out of the camp so I was like
yeah [ __ ] him like get out of here like
he's the one that's making me do all
this [ __ ] I mean it's really me doing it
but yeah I was like get out here and
then you find out later that he got
captured by the Pinkertons and he didn't
say [ __ ]
so like again there's that theme of like
no I didn't do that find really loyal
and didn't say [ __ ] about the gang but
so that makes you makes you feel bad for
kicking him out and saying this is
objectively a bad dude wow I didn't so I
I did the final one where I was just
like you know what forget your debt yeah
and but I don't think I did the like a
final final part of that yeah that's
really cool but the one where you beat
up Thomas downs and for those who don't
know if you because there's like we're
trying to rob yeah that was that was a
required yellow when he was coughing and
like seeing the look on the kids face I
was like this has to come back somehow
like originally I was like maybe this
kid will get revenge or something like
that but yeah when he starts the COFF I
was like comes back to you in multiple
ways because if you do they're optional
later on but if you finish the Downs
thing you like see her she's become a
sex worker in Anna's burg and like the
kids working in the mines he's getting
abused by the like Foreman or whatever
and you like and she hates her guts
she's like just leave us alone you like
give them money and she's like you keep
meddling in our life leave us alone and
finally he's like just take my money and
please just get out of this town and
then in addition like he's really sick
and she sees how sick he is she's like
you know I pointed out so I did that and
I gave him
money and then I came back to Anna's
burg and there was like a cutscene where
you saw her taking a john essentially
into a room and she just stepped like
you look yeah oh really she didn't leave
hatred so even you ruin her life so you
try and make amends like anything you've
you've just messed up those people's
lives and that was like it was just a
10-second thing but ya know well done I
would highly recommend doing that quests
even though we just described it like it
was really impactful just seeing her
look at you and see how sick you are and
she just knows and she sees like she
like bores into you and it's it's a lot
so so like several people have broken
out the video of you beating up Thomas
towns on YouTube so I looked it up and a
lot of commenters if you watch it it
looks like I don't know if like they
would have understood how the disease
worked enough but a lot of people
thought he spit in Arthur's face on
purpose his blood you borrowed money
from my business partner hair Strauss Oh
him he took the money he wants it back
what's not to understand I don't have it
so you place we already owe more than
it's worth then sell your wife maybe a
family or something so I thought I
thought he coughed and was just like
accidentally because they make a big
deal Arthur like wipes his face and then
on the ride back to camp after that it's
really quiet and it's cinematic mode but
there's no music or like ambient noise
just Arthur and he like wipes his lips
again I was like that felt weird that
was one of those things like you
mentioned not a place the time then
looking back I started to purpose but a
lot of people to comment to like no he
did that on purpose but I was like I
didn't I felt like that I don't know if
like hey I don't know if people in 1899
understood that you couldn't transfer
the disease through cough I think they
did actually because he know cuz Arthur
knows that's how he got it you'd think
they would understand the basics of it
but either way I thought it was just I
punched him so hard his mouth was
bleeding and he like I didn't I did
totally did not connect that he had TB
did not yeah I was just like wow I
really [ __ ] him up like
just like so not I wasn't even thinking
about it because I didn't realize that
that's how he got it until later I saw
the the nun from Santini and Arthur told
her he's like yeah I got I've got TB I'm
dying I got it from beating up this yeah
what and I was like oh so Arthur knew he
understood it but I don't know at what
point he found out but I didn't really
think about that until then then I went
back and looked at the scene I'm like oh
my god cuz i hideous down says he's not
well after you beat him up I was like
but yeah that was like so in a sense
like I think Arthur feels like he's
already paying for the shitty things
he's done so that kind of makes it even
more powerful that he's still trying to
help John because he doesn't like fully
like redeemed himself but he is dying
because of a bad deed he did and he
still chooses to try to help out the
good people of the gang which I really
loved mm-hmm
and then moving on to reigns Falls and
ego flies you kind of mentioned them
before about how getting involved in a
conflict that maybe they shouldn't be
involved in yeah I really like the
character of rains fall a lot
I think he's another one that shows
Arthur what a real leader can be where
you go riding around and picking hubs
yeah which like Rob handler entirely mr.
Rob was messaging me about that mission
cuz he was asking me like how far left
he had to go and I was like oh did you
oh that thing about Arthur's son her and
he was like what yeah you hit l2 and
talk to arrange for Ryan he was like
yeah but I asked him about his son yeah
yeah that's I really liked that it's
nice for him to open up to somebody and
I liked their relationship a lot I found
that it was very uncomfortable that set
of emissions because I mean it's
uncomfortable because in real life I
know how horribly [ __ ] up it is and
they're doing what people really did in
real life so I I was just kind of like I
know I shouldn't be here I am doing
something horrible I'm playing both
sides with these people and I'm just
ruining everyone's life
we didn't start this Arthur they did
wait st. our fact it surely is whatever
it is your planet it ain't a good idea
they want you to fight nobody will be
killed we're just gonna trap a few of
them in the valley disarm them tar and
feather them and remind them to leave
these boys alone you have energy for
Frank come on Arthur just tweaking Uncle
Sam's nose a little I need you to help
me it's really upsetting but I think
they did a good job of like making you
feel that and making it clear that what
you're doing kiss is just not OK in any
sense yeah whenever you like made
progress with reigns Falls you do a
mission with Dutch an eagle flies and
you just undo everything you did and
then you do another one and try to fix
it again and then undo and then
eventually I like how Charles is like
I'm just gonna stay here and help them
out it's really funny because you I was
talking to you and you were talking
about how so much of read that two
mirrors the first game yeah chapter sick
or was it yeah chapter 6 the getting
involved the conflict between the the
eagle like rains Falls tried and rains
Falls tribe and like the US Army the US
Army that's not the first time the game
you do that you do that with the
braithwaite's and the greys but this one
like you kind of you're fine with the
braithwaite's in the grades because
they're two rich families and it's just
like this petty squabble and I love that
chapter that's probably my favorite part
of the gameplay like rolling up yeah but
now it's got so much like Arthur's like
that was our that was kind of it was
still [ __ ] up with it now it's kind of
like I was so okay with that and now
like Jack and like for all the times
that Dutch uses he tries to like relate
to the Native Americans he's like he's
like oh we're just as wanted as you are
I'm like maybe so I was like that's not
true at all where he goes in the first
game which is sequel now you kind of see
that that's the side of that he seeds
that and he deliberately creates a gang
out of the Native Americans who have
been displaced and who he feeds off
their anger yeah totally yeah any Stokes
yeah like he Stokes their anger like and
I yeah I felt really uncomfortable
throughout
that whole time but like I do I like how
that played out ultimately oh yeah I
think it's but I think that chapter is
very well done
especially with author because he's
always he's just saying like Dutch what
the hell he doing like why why are you
doing this because because he connects
with rains fall and then I think rains
fall is really the one who kind of like
pulls him out of his loyalty to Dutch in
a way that nobody else has because he's
like yeah he's just a different kind of
leader and he sees that I will say one
of my favorite sections and I think
mechanically that supports the narrative
a lot is when the ceremonial like items
are stolen like the army steals them and
rains follows like please don't hurt
anyone please just go get them back and
I could not still that yeah I couldn't
do it and and I think that compared to
like something like warm Oh where I was
just like okay I'm tired of the same
structures this one I was like oh I I'm
not good enough like I'm not a good
enough person to not kill these dudes
like and I I thought that the structure
the similar mission structure there was
used really well because you're just
like I I tried I reloaded like three or
four times and I was just like I can't
I'm just gonna kill all of them I just
can't do it
yeah I like knowing I was doing the
mission for rains fall I like [ __ ] yeah
I'm gonna use the tomahawk just it feels
appropriate and I saw I started tomahawk
in people and then I was like I don't
know because they're the items are right
next to the campfires yeah I don't know
how anybody could done that like maybe a
distraction just to lure them out and I
tried all sorts of different approaches
I tried stealth knockouts and I wanted
to do I was like I want to be good for
him but I couldn't be I thought it was
really well done
a nice touch to that I found during
during that last chapter is when Dutch
and Arthur chased down by the cliff and
there's the river and Dutch has that
little speech about you can't fight
gravity which is also the last thing he
says in the first game I tried to fight
thing
it's a waste I see that now
it's waste you can't fight nature
captain okay fight change
you can't fight gravity that's beaches
so which like immediately I heard you
can't fight grabbed my ears perked up
it's like I know this this is cool you
know so he says that right before he
jumps off a cliff to kill himself first
game right this time he's off the cliff
to escape I guess different kinds of
escape but similar in bad sounds yeah
it's kind of nice little bow I loved
that because it was I don't know there's
so much in this game and we with what he
does with Native Americans with that
speech that you're just seeing like his
shift into what he becomes that I just
it's so all darkest so well then do we
want to talk more on Dutchess betrayal
and like how that all shakes out because
a lot of it happens in this last chapter
yeah damn like I knew at some point it
would have to come then you would do
that cuz he done that to John already
and I knew that he would do that to
Arthur at some point and it was maybe
them one of the biggest gut punches in a
game I think I've ever had because I
always assumed there would be some
loyalty still mm-hmm so Matt yeah I was
really bad son so well look you bastard
but yeah like I think when I talk about
John earlier I think that that moment
where you realize oh we're in the same
boat he wasn't gonna save you and he's
not gonna save me is a good bonding
moment for them let's talk about the
ending the ending of chapter six not the
ending of my blog I it's like that's
actually like so I feel like the I love
that the epilogue exists but I do feel
like the ending of this game is when
Arthur dies fight fighting Myka I wanted
him to kill him I wanted to kill him so
[ __ ] bad yeah seeing Dutch walk away
I I that scene didn't shake out how I
thought it would and then Arthur was
just left to like die slowly with the
Sun setting or rising so I think it's
different depending on how you played
the game so if you're honorable
how he dies I don't know yes the dreams
he has are also different throughout the
game to panic it's a wolf basically only
eddy mccooz been playing just hunter way
and he's not done so he'll tell us how
it Arthur dies but yeah it's it's like a
wolf lunging at you if you play
dishonorably and we get the like if you
played honorably which I think the game
encourages you to play honorably I think
you're kind of pushed in that direction
it's hard to beat us on or below its are
his dreams or like his dreams Oh
apparently dies the ending is supposed
to be different I don't I'm a die and
they die the same way but there's
supposed to be some difference there are
differences according to PR we don't
know there's a lot of scenes it would
have played out differently like I
wonder if Sadie would have said I was as
good of a person if I had been an hour
yeah I'm kind of curious about that
that's this playthrough now I'm trying
to be evil but I'm still too early to
really have liked me as much yeah it's I
think I think you're dead generally
pushed to being honorable and so that to
me that seems like the true ending is
like just dying at sunset on like the on
that Ridge yeah and after just like
fighting so hard and failing to kill
Micah and and apparently I didn't yeah
John alludes to this later but you give
John your saddlebag I saw that so I was
wondering why I have all of my weapons
yeah it was like oh he gave him my
satchel
you have his journal oh I didn't know
that [ __ ] yeah you can and John writes
in it what the journal but you can look
back on Arthur's journal but um I didn't
I didn't see anything like that no if I
was crying but my horse dying or
whatever
so so much the same horse so Tennessee
Walker my horse is the big one that
Hosea you get with Hosea like the really
is called shot oh the one you can sell
you can select him and I sold the one
that the game forced me to buy in that
weird mission and named him Biff and I
have you know had Biff throughout this
whole 60 plus I was and then Biff dies
and I was going oh and then I was like
yeah cradling the horse I was like you
see they
he whispers thank you to the horse I
[ __ ] called so I was like forever and
then after one of my Pat's and he died
and then all of a sudden like he's like
thank you all the dudes who shot him was
like [ __ ] all of you so I missed if he
gives Jonathan saddle bag I saw that I
did see that but I didn't see him giving
him is like he's a what do you call it
his personal yeah accoutrement yeah
shoutout to the music and the like the
whole soundtrack is grating like I
cannot wait for that I like the death
song better than there's another song
stand unshaken I love that song there's
a song before that when you're riding
it's when it's when Arthur says he has
to go solve something back at camp it's
before the when mrs. Grimshaw gets
killed when Micah kills her it's before
the yeah and there's a song in the way
back that sounded like like a soap opera
like a John Mayer song almost like
things cut it in with like dialogue from
like oh yeah it was so heavy like I gave
it's like it felt
I think stun and shaking yeah yeah that
was great
I think my favorite song is from the the
final like epilogue mission when you're
on the mountain though yes it's like the
the remixed expand not remix but like
the expanded version of the Red Dead one
theme and yeah I mean this is again
epilogue talk but when you do that first
mission and you're saving the
neighboring ranch and it's the first
time they used the Red Dead 1 music yeah
box and he puts on his rhythm fest
the first time you see I guess we just
jump right on the epilogue then
but yeah I mean I think it's you you put
here about how it's interesting seeing
John try to kind of find the American
dream legally yeah he's like he's got
land he's trying to buy land he's in
debt to the bank the whole bank sequence
is like oh we own you now you're true
American and it's like that yeah that
was it went back to like it was oh very
rock star that whole a lot of way it was
a really good bridge between red that
too which is like one of the only rock
star games that I felt like had a warm
story and then the like cynicism of Reds
at one and like all the GTA games and
it's like oh you own you now and you
could see that like tonal transition
which is awesome and like well what's
great is like that you can look at that
is just like oh we own you that's a
funny line but they actually do own John
and that's like the whole plot of Red
Dead one is the fact that the guns now
owns John yeah I feel like so much of
this game mirrors the first game and we
talked about this a little bit in ways
that reminded me of like the way force
awakens mirrors and you hope and that I
don't think it's like like there's some
things that I predicted would happen
because I'm like well this is a lot like
what happened in one but I found them to
be really smart mirrors in a lot of ways
and so I think that the in section where
you're like just learning how to build a
fence and like helping a kid break a
horse and like that stuff is a lot like
the end of one where you're teaching
Jack those things and I think it has the
same impact of like okay we're slowing
down like we're really trying here but
something keeps coming up and he's just
not escaping it else when you're going
back to the lumberyard after you build
the house which again that was cool just
like building the house that you know
but when you're starting to build the
barn and you're thinking about how John
dies you're like oh wait because it was
the barn right where he's like kicks
over the door to go and he dies he gets
shot so the first time I walked through
those doors in this game I got chills
yeah I was like this is his laughs this
is the last thing John does yeah these
walks out these days like a reverse of
yeah definitely when I walked into the
bar and the I think it's when you get
drunk with uncle and Charles after you
built the house and you wake up and you
kind of go outside and you're on the the
where your grave will ultimately be that
is what got me cuz I was like oh this is
what my wife's grave is yeah like at the
very after you've like after the credits
when you come in and John and Abigail
are standing on the ridge overlooking
the house and the exact spot where their
graves will be and Abigail's like I love
it like that crushed me so much I was
like no they feel like they finally
escaped the young days and you know what
happens like I would say like by and
large I until the Beppe log I didn't
think you needed to play the first game
there's some cool things but like the
epilogue I don't think the epilogue if I
didn't play the first game I would be
like well I don't want to do any of this
yeah none of this means anything it's
similar to like what you said at the end
of the first game like why am i ranching
and then you realize it's to set up the
relationship and then have Jack kind of
get revenge but this I was like I and
this is long this is like a seven eight
hour epilogue yeah oh my god that was
like one like when we were talking about
features and stuff there was like oh
should you play the first one like how
much do you know and I was trying to
like not spoil anything but I was saying
like yes you should absolutely play the
first one because the epilogue will be
long and bloated and you probably won't
appreciate it I mean it's still fun but
I think your knowledge of the first one
is super important for that I think it
is but bringing Sadie and Charles in
there helps that's true and having the
Myka stuff helps yeah but yeah like the
like the whole proposal sequence is one
of my favorite things in the entire game
I loved that mission so much such a
nervous and awkward
that's a nice respite from everything
else you're doing you you go take the
photo she's like what are you doing you
[ __ ] like what is this this is not like
you you get out on the boat and that was
just the cutest I was like he's actually
trying with her she left him he left her
he abandoned them at the beginning of
Jack's life like he's finally getting
his [ __ ] together and it's very cute and
also that's the whole thing like was
completely bittersweet I think from that
point onwards is when I was kind of like
had a lump in my throat because yeah
what's gonna happen and especially
during the credits as well as their help
of these little vignettes of the wedding
everyone in the wedding
went dancing and Sadie leaving them and
Charles leaving them and oh I just it
was so well done and I and it was the
kind of payoff that's after you know I
guess if you put both games together
you're talking about what like a hundred
hours mm-hmm and it just felt like such
a good undeserved
emotional reaction for me like I don't
that were the game since maybe like Mass
Effect 3 mm-hmm where you have such a
connection to these characters you know
even though like you don't really in the
grand scheme of things spend that much
time with Abigail it felt like it was
more quality time spent with her in the
epilogue oh yes and I wanted that to
last forever I was like I'm just the the
because you know he has a couple years
they have they have like what three
years or something four years
so one thing they didn't talk about
which I would I was kind of surprised
about is the fact that they actually had
another child
the daughter yeah who didn't get
mentioned as far as I can tell he
mentions her to Bonnie in the first game
and she dies and like with cholera right
yeah yeah and I don't know if they just
thought hey maybe that's gonna be too
sad yeah let's keep this on and up guys
um or maybe that that's what happens in
between the closing credits of two and
the start of one also the problem with
the timeline of that is I think it's
Javier says something about your
children which would imply that the
daughter was alive when the gang was
still together
yeah and she would have died but
sometime yeah in between the events of
one and two that means to be fair like
I'm kind of glad they didn't because I
think that would have just that would've
been especially like during that
epilogue stuff that would have been
really rough to have that happen I think
and the way you can explain away the
children comment is that like that's
more of a progeny like children in the
general sense if like oh you're you're
who's coming after you so you can just
say like I have one maybe right like you
can explain that away it's not like a
huge cannon breaking thing but yeah I
mean today no I really did like how
from those like post-credits like little
vignettes you don't really have to you
don't really end up interacting with
like Ross at all it kind of it's just
like the rest of the like you can you're
free to mess around do it everyone as
John Marcin which is something I
desperately wanted in the first time I
did I like Jack but I did not want to
play as Jack yeah yeah cuz his voice
actor and and I don't know just you get
so attached to John Marston and I think
it's brilliant the first thing that you
don't get to play is John Marston at the
end but I still wish you didn't I think
it's it's it's an incredible feeling to
finish the game and have nothing to do
except just be John Marston and yeah
kind of explore the world Asim but there
is one scene that we should still
probably talk about which is the final
scene when you ascend the mountain and
the music plays and you so good it's
really good it's hard it is hard I got a
couple that was the first time in the
game I used tonics like regularly I was
like I better supercharge my health I
loved that I was happy to die I was like
well distance music again yeah but I
wasn't expecting to see touch it really
wasn't I here was I I thought he'd just
kind of stop it but I think I think
shooting Micah when he was holding a gun
to Sadie's head was finally like I think
maybe he knew all along that Micah was
the one who like he because Arthur told
him he's like Micah wasn't one to talked
and like Michael's like he's lying his
dumb voice but I think Dutch knew all
along but he recognized that Micah was
helping advance his own self-interests
yeah I think finally shooting him was
the ultimate like I only care about
myself like this all along has been
about me and that was really cool too
because it take it almost takes the
revenge out of it like yeah you come
there and you kill all of all of the the
grunt members of that new gang they
founded but like Dutch is the one who
shoots Micah and it's like I found that
really well done I really liked that
well you I saw it sorry so he starts he
shoots him once and then you can [ __ ]
light him off so there's no
oh yeah I thought I wanted to do that
and then all of a sudden John just pulls
his gun and it's highlighting all the
weak areas yeah no it's nice to shoot
him after that but I thought like the
initial shot coming from Dutch impactful
cuz I was gonna shoot yeah I was like I
thought for sure he'd kill Charles and
Sadie just to wrap up those stories so
happy to see that they were still around
where is our like Sadie bounty hunter
DLC I just want to like I want to be
able to feel agreement because I don't
want to ruin John's life I don't want to
do bounty hunter [ __ ] as John I want
John to enjoy his like three remaining
years of his wife and child and uncle
yeah and this one you online you be able
to cut your own character but I have a
feeling should be like a quest giver a
mission giver like but I I think it
would be really cool if we see like
maybe two DLCs Charles and Sadie know
just the kind of stories yeah it was
great but I think one last thing we're
running out of time but one thing we
should probably talk about is did you
guys have a chance to explore new austin
at all yes Donn's well first of all the
mission with Sadie when you were
I think the first bounty you do with
Sadie is in the first place you go with
Lee Johnson hmm and you take out a gang
there who've been yeah the bolars I
think the whole gang so that was nice
but then I went down to armadillo and I
actually did like a kind of weird thing
like I did a lot of role-playing when I
was playing the game itself and like
taking things super slowly and taking
the line and when I when I was looking
at going between Blackwater and
armadillo like I pretty much knew the
way which is weird for a game that I
haven't played in you know five to eight
years but I recognized so many so much
when I was approaching armadillo I kind
of got off my horse and I just
Dinn and then for it to be pretty much
in flames everyone's gone because of the
color I thought sure it's a clever plot
device but I kind of wish there had been
a little more there yeah cuz I went to
McFarlane ranch and there was no one
there I feel people would just no one
but I do enjoy it mmm soul-crushing Lee
I did find the body of Bonnie's
betrothed who had a love letter that was
to her and I was like okay yeah I'm
thinking I'm fine with not seeing Bonnie
because I've had this moment but it's
super easy to miss you did not get that
it was a corpse had washed up ashore and
I was like okay that's that's fine but
going to McFarland mansion like looking
around the you know the hut that she
puts you in and around armadillo and I
was like oh hey that's the room that I
rented in the saloon and stuff you don't
know this yet John but you're gonna live
here at one mA yeah did you go to a
tumbleweed cuz tumbleweed is no longer a
ghost town which is pretty cool I think
that's super cool yeah I didn't these do
me tell you what it's in thievery it's
not that exciting it's just a gang
hideout which makes sense right cuz in
the game they talk about how it's like
basically just a gang hideout it's kind
of civilized but tumbleweed not being a
ghost town is super cool yeah there's
like a there's like a general store you
there's specific clothing to tumbleweed
and like they kind of hint at what
happens I think like a guy comes in with
a bounty and throws him down and he's
like this we caught this guy and he's
like if you guys hang me like 47
Mexicans are gonna roll through here and
burn this town to the ground and chase
everyone out and and the sheriff's like
we don't take threats from gang members
and just shoot some and then and then
like I don't know me I'm just assuming
that that's probably what happens it's
humble we it is they get a warning and
everyone who's leaves no like a world
I'd be pretty cool what a good question
yeah anything else before we wrap this
up the closing credits song is a bang is
that the Josh I've been listening to it
on repeat cuz I don't know josh homme he
was in this game until
and I got an EMP seized yeah so much
voice is so good there's probably a an
array of things that I would like to
talk about but I guess they're minor in
the big picture it's been over an hour
already
yeah there's so much I still want to see
I guess is the final note like I still
need to just ride around I'm gonna I do
I do like how the game handles the
existing side quest givers when you go
back as John they'll kind of they kind
of like recap it like previously on but
they do it like normally they're like
who was it the artist I forget his name
his initial or CC and San Denis the
French guy he he'll be like you kind of
the way you figure out that you both
knew yeah him guy that you both knew
Arthur or like it's kind of yes man
pretty well done when you hunt down the
gunslingers if you don't finish that and
go to talk to the the author he'll be
our John will be like so this is kind of
weird you don't know me but I have my
friends like notes here and he mentioned
you then you might need help with
something yeah so there's two people I
want to shout out the guy looking for
Gavin gets in Blackwater yeah and he was
yeah he was like all disheveled and he
was a mess and he's like Gavin and like
he's he's like slowly unraveling and
John's just like I'm a good one and then
I want to talk about Mickey the veteran
the one-armed veteran in Valentine if
you go back to him as John he's like I
knew a fellow like you he didn't like me
much either but he at least listened to
me and well if you actually were nice to
him as Arthur yeah I mean he I hugged
him I was very uncomfortable he spoke
very highly of my Arthur really yeah he
was like he was like you remind me of a
fella a fella who was like super nice
and like yeah yeah he I mean he he has
he admits that he's not actually a
veteran but like his uh it was nice to
go back and see him and I thought that
was a cool touch yeah
with the eight-year wait isn't everyone
thing I didn't wait it yours
so no don't think I think so yeah sure
well that's our spoiler chat I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did we still have
plenty of more Red Dead stuff coming
including our show quick-draw which this
is a part of this is an episode of quick
draw I believe you'll see and dirty
Artie which is where we make Arthur as
much of a mess as possible but that's it
thank you guys for joining me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]